chris was buzzing tonight largest crowd
so far this season
yeah more than 12 thousand fans were
there hoping to watch the golden knight
just close out the first round of the
playoffs but
the wild had other plans and send the
series now back to minnesota
sports director chris matthews starts
our team coverage tonight with a game
five recap chris i think it's a three
hour flight denise again
the golden knights have never won a
playoff series on home ice they
have a chance to make history tonight
with a win over minnesota remember the
last year
they raced out to that 3-1 lead over
vancouver only to see the canuck sports
at game seven
boy they'd love to wrap it up over 12
000 fans at the fortress cheering him on
mark stone lights the lamp giving vegas
the first goal they gave his fourth post
season
and look at the reaction that tells the
story but right after that celebration
the wild
would answer with three goals on their
first six shots on goal
that's the first time in vegas playoff
history they'd allowed three in the
first vegas dominated the second period
knights one for 19 in the power play
make it two for 20. alec martinez scores
vegas outshot the wild 23-1 in the
second
tuck almost scores here knights
dominated the second and third periods
but it's the wildly forcing game six
winning 4-2
you know we're looking forward to game
six um i i think great you know aft
after
uh after a game like that you want to
you know you want to rest and regroup
and
uh re-energize so that it's important
that tomorrow
we do that and you know we'll be ready
to go in game six we put ourselves we've
worked hard to put ourselves in a really
good spot here
and uh you know we'll go and try and
take advantage of it in game six
all right the two teams will meet again
on wednesday so all those fans who are
hoping to celebrate a win they go home
disappointed
kevin martin caught up with a few
medieval maniacs and joins us
live from inside the fortress hey kevin
hey chris the largest crowd all season
long was on hand here at the fortress
tonight for game five
12 156 fans
packed inside t-mobile arena hoping the
golden knights could close things out
here tonight but
it wasn't in the cards as the wild
walked away with a 4-2
win but despite the loss fans are
staying optimistic
that the golden knights can close things
out in game six on wednesday
i understand the economics of the series
going to
all seven games however there were some
major
penalties that should have been called
they didn't call them
no we didn't play our best but they
tried hard and
it was just the luck of the draw we will
get them in game six
you got to love the optimism but yeah
chris you mentioned it earlier it's
crazy to think
everything that the golden knights have
accomplished in their four seasons in
the nhl
but they have still yet to close out a
playoff series here
on home ice reporting live inside the
fortress kevin martin eight sport